Salut la team Mentalo !
Y a quelques semaines environ j'ai essayé de battre Akinator
Et aujourd'hui, c'est vous qui allez le combattre
Juste avant de commencer je voulais vous préciser que pour ma venue en Suisse
je vais faire un meet-up avec  Chico Nono, je vous en dis plus à la fin de la vidéo
Parce que pour l'instant...générique !
Ça fait un petit moment que j'avais envie de refaire une vidéo avec Akinator
Mais on ne va pas faire comme la dernière fois quand j'étais avec Romain
(pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu la vidéo je vous la mets ici)
Alors comment ça va se passer aujourd'hui ?
Et bah je vais vous le dire comment ça va se passer
J'ai choisi deux personnes et un objet à l'avance
Je vais essayer de les faire deviner à Akinator mais vous, en temps réel, avec les questions que je pose à Akinator
Vous devez essayer de les trouver également
C'est donc le battle Team Mentalo - Akinator !
Utilisez votre esprit de synthèse, votre concentration, votre logique
Et je suis sûr que vous allez trouver au moins un ou deux, ou voire les trois
Le personnage est-il de sexe féminin ?
Non !
Ton personnage habite-t-il en France ?
Oui, même si on ne sait pas réellement où ce personnage habite
En tous cas il y a une légende urbaine là-dessus
Ton personnage a-t-il vendu des disques ?
Non
Ton personnage est-il un youtubeur ?
Oui !
(et bah dis donc il va vite)
Ton personnage a-t-il fait des vidéos avec Cyprien ?
Non je ne pense pas
Ton personnage fait-il partie du milieu du jeu vidéo ?
Alors pas vraiment, pas exactement
Je vais mettre non
Ton personnage a-t-il plus de 18 ans ?
Oui
Ton personnage a-t-il un rapport avec le milieu du sport ?
Et là je vais cliquer sur le...
Et non, ce n'est pas du tout Tibo InShape
Ton personnage porte-t-il des lunettes ? Non.
Ton personnage est-il en couple avec une femme ?
Je sais pas
Ton personnage se produit-il sur scène ?
Non
On est déjà à onze, douze questions
Si vous avez déjà trouvé, vous, vous pouvez le mettre dans les commentaires
Ton personnage est il de couleur de peau métisse?
Non
Ton personnage fait il des vidéos comiques?
Non, même si il me fait rire mais non
Ton personnage a t il une moto?
Non
Ton personnage a t il un rapport avec le monde culinaire?
Non plus
Rapport avec les extra-terrestres?
Non ce n'est pas Sylvain Durif
Ton personnage fait il des tests high tech?
Oui
Oula il y a une question qui a sauté
J'ai vu un truc passé oui ce truc était bon
Ton personnage fait il des vidéos de déballage de produits?
Oui
Ouuuuiiiiii c'était Romain de TechNews & Test,
c'était pour voir si vous aviez regardé la vidéo précédente sur Akinator,
parce que c'était avec Romain que je l'avais faite.
J'ai pas vu, je crois qu'on était à 15 ou 16 questions
peut être vous aviez trouvé.
Deuxième test,
possibilité encore une fois de marqué un point pour vous
Déjà 1 point pour Akinator si il a trouvé avant vous en tout cas.
Avec un nouveau personnage.
Ton personnage est il dans le domaine de la musique?
Non
Est il un Youtubeur?
Est il masculin?
Oui
Ton personnage a t il plus de 30ans?
Non
Je vous le dis tout de suite pour connaitre il faut un peu regarder les vidéos quand même
Ton personnage a t il déjà vu ton visage?
Oooooooh oui
Si ton personnage le souhaitait accepterais tu une relation amoureuse avec lui?
Non, j'aime ce personnage mais non
As tu les mêmes parents que ton personnage?
Non
Ton personnage porte t il des vêtements?
Non, mon personnage est tout le temps nu
Ton personnage a t il eu une histoire qui a mal tourné avec la Fouine?
Non, sauf si il y a une embrouille que je ne connais pas
Est ce que ton personnage est un chien?
Non
Est ce que ton personnage est un chat?
Oui
mon personnage est un chat oui
Est ce qu'il vit avec moi?
Oui il vit avec moi oui
Alors c'est pas du tout la bonne photo mais oui c'était mon chat, c'est Tamalo.
Vous l'avez déjà vu dans des vidéos précédentes Tamalo
Si vous avez juste trouvé que je parlais de mon chat
on peut dire que vous avez battu Akinator
Si vous avez trouvé que je parlais de Tamalo précisément
alors là vous avez un point bonus
Troisième partie c'est sur un objet
J'ai jamais fait avec les objets
On joue avec les objets et il me pose comme question est ce un objet?
Alors en plus c'est pas si évident que ça
Est ce un objet? ... Roh je dis Oui
même plutôt
Est ce que ça a un rapport avec le sexe?
Direct, en fait, euh...
alors potentiellement tout peu avoir rapport mais...
je ne pense pas non
Est ce que ça pèse plus de 10Kg?
Non
Est ce que ça sert à se divertir?
Est ce qu'on le porte sur soi?
Non
Est ce que ça se trouve dans une cuisine?
mmmmhhhh plutôt
Est ce que ça se met dans la bouche?
Euh... oui. Du coup, je comprends mieux la deuxième question
Est ce que le contenu est liquide?
Oui
Est ce qu'il y a de l'alcool?
Non
Non pas vraiment
Est ce que ça a un lien avec le sens de la vie?
Eh bien, et ben pour moi Oui
mais je vais mettre Non quand même
Est ce que c'est gazeux?
Non
Est ce que ça se mâche?
Est ce qu'il y a un bouchon?
Non
Est ce une boisson?
Oui
Là je sens que dans les commentaires ça fait j'ai trouvéééé
ou pas.
Est ce que c'est chaud?
Non
Est ce que c'est coupant?
Mais qu'est ce qui se boit et qui peut être coupant.
est ce que vous avez un exemple concret d'un truc qui se boit et qui coupe comme ça la langue.
Est ce qu'il y a plusieurs couleurs?
Non il y en a qu'une
Est ce naturel?
euh.... oui plutôt
Est ce que ça contient du poisson?
Non
Est ce que ça se pratique en famille?
est ce qu'un objet peut se pratiquer en famille
J'en sais rien.
Ça peut être utile dans l'eau?
Ben oui
Ça permet de faire du jus?
Non
Un thé glacé
et bien pas du tout
donc on continue
Moi je pense que vous êtes nombreux à avoir déjà trouvé
On continue Oui
pfffffffff
C'est... une cata.
On est parti sur une tarte au citron
ou je suis vraiment un looser dans mes réponses
est ce qu'il me le propose là?
même pas.
Pas du tout
Je pensais, évidemment,
à une menthe à l'eau
On a posé une colle à Akinator
mais comme vous étiez en battle avec lui.
Si vous avez trouvé. Alors vous avez gagné au moins une manche sur Akinator
Dites moi dans les commentaires ce que vous aimeriez que je fasse d'autres avec Akinator
Ça me fait vraiment marrer de faire des vidéos avec
donc ça serait sympa d'en faire une 3ème un jour par forcément tout de suite
mais un jour.
Mettez moi vos idées dans les commentaires
Comme je vous le disais le 21 et 22 octobre prochain. Je vais être en spectacle à Lausanne
à Ouchy un petit peu au Sud de Lausanne
Au CPO.
A l'occasion, avec un YouTubeur  que vous avez déjà vu sur ma chaîne on organise un meet-up
un petit peu en collaboration tout les 2 ensembles
C'est Noam alias Chico Nono
Ça me fait toujours rire quand je dis son nom
Il y a 6 places en tout à gagner pour le spectacle
il y a un meet up avec lui
et il y a un espèce de Meet and greet avec lui et moi à la fin de mon spectacle
Je vous laisse aller voir sur sa chaîne en cliquant sur ce lien ici
Pour voir tout les détails de ça dans sa dernière vidéo
et j'en profite pour vous rappelez qu'il y a toutes les dates de spectacle de ma tournée qui sont sur mon site internet
dont vous avez le lien dans la description
Toute la province et Paris fin décembre et une grosse soirée spéciale à Versailles le 31 décembre également
Voilà pour aujourd'hui les Mentalos
Demain ça sera enfin la vidéo du Mind Map
Vous en avez envoyé foison, moulte.
Ils sont vraiment excellents
Prenez le temps d'un petit clip pour vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Des fois vous regardez les vidéos souvent et vous avez pas percuté que vous étiez pas encore abonné
et un petit clic c'est rapide
Et rendez vous demain à 17h.
Tchao !